Oops.
Hold on.
Hello.
Welcome to Outer Wilds Echoes of the Eye.
The theme song.
I know.
I've been sitting here, just like, tearing up.
Listening to it.
Thank you for the vibe gift.
Thank you so much.
Two months already.
Let's go.
Thank you, Moth.
And Foxplay.
Thank you.
Hearing this music, I'm gonna cry.
It's so wet.
Yes, I'm super duper excited to be playing the DLC of Outer Wilds.
I saw some people saying, like, oh, I didn't see Outer Wilds on Mint's channel.
But I have played it before.
That's why I'm not streaming it, because it's kind of...
And I played it kind of recently.
It's hard...
It's a difficult game to replay.
In a sense.
Because...
Well, I mean, just...
I mean, not difficult.
But, like...
If you've played it, then I think you understand.
Can't really unlearn it.
Exactly.
I would already know all the puzzles, and where to go, and all this and that.
Thank you for all the fun, and for being so kind.
It's always nice hanging out in your streams.
What?
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Why?
Thank you so much.
Oh my goodness.
I'd recommend playing through the base game first, but I got a feeling that you're smart enough to just start with the DLC.
I have played it.
Yeah, so...
Yeah...
You would have to erase your memory.
I know!
So, I'm a little sad that...
That I already played it, so I can't stream it here.
But...
But, I can do the DLC!
So...
That I have not played yet, at all.
I actually know zero things about it.
And...
Let's see...
The summary called you an A.I.
G.W.
Turn off the PC right now.
What's really funny, too, is Outer Wilds is a game that...
I only really ever see these comments...
For Outer Wilds.
Of people saying that they can't watch the stream...
Because they want to play the game themselves.
Or they're in the middle of playing the game.
So...
It's pretty funny.
But it is definitely...
If you have not played the game before...
Maybe you've watched someone play it.
Which I guess is okay, too.
Definitely one of those types of games, though.
That...
Is so highly recommended.
You know?
Completely valid.
Of course!
I had to stop watching someone play it, too.
To do that, too.
Yeah.
It's...
It's totally valid.
And so I...
Part of me is just like...
Hmm...
Should I even stream it at all?
You know?
But...
I also...
Truly enjoy...
Sharing these types of memories with you guys.
So...
You know...
I do choose to sometimes play things.
Even though the people are like...
No, no.
You should play this.
And take it in yourself.
But I also kinda like...
You know?
Having our little...
I like having my...
Reactions...
And my...
You know?
My first time reactions...
Recorded.
Because you can never take that back!
You know?
Once you...
Once you experience something...
You can never experience it for the first time again!
And so...
If I can watch myself...
You know?
In the future...
I can go back...
And watch...
Like...
If I'm just like...
Thinking about her wiles...
I can be like...
How did I react to this?
You know?
So...
Hmm...
She doesn't hate us?
Um...
So...
Actually...
For this...
Uh...
I don't know exactly...
Um...
I...
I tried looking it up without...
Looking it up...
Um...
The closest I'll ever get to playing Outer Wilds again is watching someone else experience it for the first time.
Thanks for streaming it for us.
Ah!
Thank you!
Thanks for the super chat, Yura!
Mr. Yura!
Thank you!
Yeah!
I feel that way too, though.
Right?
Um...
You can resume.
Well...
So...
I actually...
Re-bought the game.
Because I had the other...
My...
I played it...
I played it before on a different account.
And I...
Um...
Had to re-buy the game.
And...
Um...
Uh...
The TLC.
So...
Um...
Actually...
I just played like a little bit of it yesterday.
So...
Um...
I was kind of...
Because I was worried.
I was just like...
Do I...
Need to have beaten the game...
Before?
But it seems like...
As long as I have the knowledge...
I don't have a problem.
I don't have to have...
It...
In my save file.
Um...
From what I understand...
That's correct.
Okay.
Good.
Down!
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
It might change some things.
Wait.
My ship log.
I know.
I was looking at it.
I was like...
Oh man.
I kind of want to do like a summary.
Like...
Wow.
What happened?
Everything.
But...
Um...
If...
You guys tell me that I must have...
Completed the game...
In...
In the fact that I need a...
Completed save file...
I...
Do have access to that.
So...
Um...
I don't...
Oh!
What the heck?
OBS just disconnected.
I think YouTube is having some issues...
Today.
Um...
So...
The DLC ending is better if you completed the game before.
Which I have.
I have completed the game before.
I have the knowledge in my brain.
Spanking Hive!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Parts of the ship log will affect elements of the DLC.
Ah ha.
I'm sorry.
What should I do?
It doesn't matter.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Maybe it's okay then.
It doesn't matter.
Okay.
Then I'm just gonna resume.
And...
Hopefully it's okay.
Okay.
That feels so cool.
Being here again.
So yeah.
I kind of...
Here.
I can even show you...
Like I started the game yesterday.
Oh!
I already got them from the observ...
See?
I literally only did one loop.
Thanks for streaming this.
Thank you for the super chat!
I already got them.
Must be inhaling more fumes than I realized.
That stuff is potent.
Well, if you've got the codes, I'm not gonna stop you.
Good luck and take care of that ship.
Bye.
There's a lot of fumes.
Let's see.
My poor ship log.
I went to Giants Deep.
And that's about all I did.
I saw Gabbro.
I saw the bro.
That's all.
Everything else is...
Look.
Oh.
Whoops.
Everything else is...
It's totally empty.
It feels so... I was like, no!
I've done more!
All you need is the Quantum Moon and the center of the Interloper.
Oh.
You didn't go to the Bramble?
No way!
No way.
Did you get meditation?
No, I think I needed to have gone through a loop first to get the meditation.
So maybe before we do the DLC maybe I will grab...
Oh wait.
Maybe I will grab a couple things, right?
Maybe it would be good.
Core things that make the DLC better that add scenes are visiting the comet and your teleporting moon friend mainly.
But it's not essential.
Okay.
But I do kind of want the full experience, right?
Because I beat the game.
So it's kind of like...
Oh.
Am I going to make it?
Ouch.
Oh god.
Nobody saw that.
Oh my goodness, that is so loud.
I might need your help then.
If you guys are backseaters, rejoice.
I might need your help then a little bit.
With exactly where I need to go if you guys don't mind a little bit.
And if you don't mind a little bit of exploration before we get into the DLC itself.
Finally, it's our time to shine.
Yeah, like it just opened its eyes and they're like...
Wowee.
But the DLC is here, right?
New exhibit.
The radio tower here on Timber Hearth was built to receive transmissions from our deep space satellite.
And to this day still houses the first ever photos taken of the entire solar system.
Am I in the way?
These photos were made possible by the deep space satellite's unusual vertical orbit that carries it high above and below the plane of the solar system.
Oh so it's the radio tower, not here.
Thanks to a recent upgrade, the deep space satellite is now responsible for generating the real time solar system map used by our newest astronauts.
Okay.
Hello quantum... unusual signal.
So creepy.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Um, hello?
Eww.
These fish.
These dang stinkin' fish.
You have your textures on one eighth.
I was worried about my computer.
Maybe I'll change it.
Wait.
Oh you know what, I'll just do full.
I think I changed everything else from very high to high though.
Except... yeah.
Should be fine then.
Corky!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Absolutely adore this game.
Have fun with the DLC.
Thank you Waffle & Sign!
Thank you!
Waffles...
Can I leave the menu?
That's amazing that you could tell immediately.
You were like, um, your textures are not optimal.
That's so crazy.
Crazy.
The pictures were very crunchy.
Oh, was that because... was that why?
Oh you're right!
I'm like, wow!
How could you tell?
I thought that's just how they were supposed to be.
Okay.
I get it.
I was like, wow.
I can't see anything.
Alrighty.
Wow, it's such a nice day.
To die.
Oh wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh, I'm fine.
Let's go back to our ship.
And let's go get some of the things that we need for an optimal game.
And let's go get some of the things that we need for an optimal ending.
So happy to see you again, Minto!
Thank you!
Oh wait, I'm gonna die here.
Um,
oopsie.
I forgot that.
Um...
I'm gonna turn the audio down just a little bit.
Quite loud.
Oh, whoopsie!
Oh, that's fine!
We have the full day now, right?
We have the full day.
It's all good.
Whoopsie!
Okay.
So, you guys said the meteor?
The interloper?
Um...
Oh gosh, how do I get there again?
Hmm...
Uh...
It wasn't just crash landing on it, right?
Or...
Just fly onto it?
Interloper and quantum moon.
How do I get to the quantum moon again?
Do you remember how to get to the quantum moon?
Um...
I can just fly to the interloper.
Okay, let's fly there then.
Let's not fly into the sun.
Where's the sun?
Over there.
Okay, we're good.
Okay.
Alright.
Where's our interloper, friend?
Hmm...
Somewhere.
Giant state.
Is that the moon?
Right there?
Oh gosh.
What was it again?
Um...
I'll remember.
Eventually.
I'll remember eventually.
Wait!
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Um...
Did it have to do with...
With the camera?
Right?
Is that it?
No, that's some...
What is that?
Why is left stick not doing anything?
Hmm...
Is that the...
The white hole moon?
Or the station?
White hole station?
Yes?
Jeffrey!
Are you actually here?
Um...
Jeffrey, I had to make a new game.
So I'm getting some of the stuff...
Wait!
Nope, that's just a really bright star.
Where the heck is this thing?
Hello?
Interloper.
Uh-uh.
Go into your settings and rewind.
Maybe I have to.
Controls...
Oh wait.
Movement?
Just kidding.
Um...
Should be fine, right?
Wait.
Flight.
Lock on.
Yeah, I've been pressing down on L, F.
Hmm, weird.
Ducky, thanks for the gift card!
Hmm...
Jeffrey said known bug.
I'm getting a sense of deja vu.
I don't know about you!
Okay, hold on.
How do I unbind it?
Uh...
Oh.
Wait.
Okay.
I'm sorry, the lock-on bug has haunted me for years.
Just rewind lock-on again.
Okay, thank you, Jeffrey.
I'm playing this because...
I...
I saw that you were able to...
Or I heard, rather, that you were able to meet...
Matara Ofukai.
Unless she's a liar.
But I got your note.
Thank you.
Couple things for the 10 gifted!
Where the heck is...
Okay, let's see if it works now.
Oh!
Yippee!
Okay.
I'm looking for the interloper.
I'm looking for...
The interloper.
Wait.
Is that the...
No, that's Ash Twin.
I was like, is that the sun station?
I wonder...
Wait, where did the Quantum Moon go?
Wait!
I see it!
I'm gonna miss it.
It's gonna go straight to the sun.
Wait.
Hold on.
Interloper!
I see you!
Yes!
Use your map?
It's more fun to use my eyes a little bit, right?
Oh, gosh.
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to reach this.
Casey!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you.
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
Okay.
We might be fine.
Maybe.
Coming in hot.
How do I...
I don't remember how to...
Okay.
I'm coming in real hot.
Oh, great!
Here I am!
Interloper!
Oh, my goodness.
How do I land again?
I don't remember.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
Bonk!
Oh, shoot!
I don't wanna die!
Wait!
I'm here!
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
Please.
Interloper!
Let me on you!
Okay.
I'm falling.
I'm in the gravity source.
Gravitational pole.
Wait.
How do I go down?
Here we go.
Oh, please.
Please.
It's been a minute since I've played this game.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna reach the sun.
Wait.
Oh, god.
Please.
Let me on you.
Okay.
Ouch!
It's fine.
Just a scratch.
Alright.
We're here.
Just don't jump.
Whatever you do, little alien.
We're there.
Here.
Ouch.
Okay.
We're good.
This is a thing I need.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay.
The shuttle may freeze entirely.
I got my Mentara postcard today!
I think it got caught in a conveyor.
Oh, no!
Really?
Avi!
Thanks for the...
50?
Oh.
Wait.
Hold on.
Sorry.
If I click out of the...
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh.
Next page.
Sorry.
I'm gonna skip some...
Actually, no.
I'm not gonna skip through it.
Because I want a good recap.
Right?
Even if it did...
Couldn't someone call it back home to the Gravity Cannon on Ember Twin?
Takes quite the specimen to nearly miss falling off the ground.
Stop!
Yes.
But the exploration of the comet would be more difficult if we were without the shuttle until someone recalled it.
Perhaps we shouldn't have landed on the dark side of the comet.
Suppose one of us remained in the shuttle to keep it warm and continue monitoring the surface.
This would be wise, I think, Clary.
If you don't mind waiting here with it, Poki and I can continue to investigate the surface.
So...
From my memory...
The comet is basically the cause of, like, their overall demise.
Right?
There was, like, the...
It had, like, the stuff inside...
Oh, sorry.
Spoilers!
If you have not played, please don't watch the stream.
The ghost matter!
The ghost matter.
Yes.
So, basically, I remember going into the comet and just seeing them dead in there.
It's so sad.
Okay.
Ship log updated.
Can we get inside there?
Was there a way to?
Or... maybe there wasn't.
Can I get inside...
Oh, how do I get inside the comet now?
Go in there again for the log?
Yeah, yeah.
I just have to figure out how to get in.
When it's near the sun, it's gotta melt, right?
Oh, no!
Wait!
It already...
Oh, shoot.
Why did you spread your matter all over the solar system?
It's just, you know...
ghosty things, right?
Where's my ship?
Oh, no!
Really?
It won't go back to the sun, right?
I think we won't have the chance to...
Um...
Hmm...
Well, shoot.
I have to be really fast then, don't I?
That's okay.
We have one more pass, but not for a while.
Well, I'm...
I'm here, so...
I might run out of oxygen, though.
Where did my ship go?
Maybe I can reach my ship.
Whoa!
Ship!
Um...
I don't wanna...
Oh, gosh.
The bramble.
Ship!
Ship, ship, ship!
Oh, my God.
It's so close.
I'm just gonna jump for it.
You guys, I'm gonna jump for it.
I'm coming for you!
Ship!
It's in the gravitational pull, so...
Wait, can I actually match its velocity?
Come on, ship.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
I might have enough fuel.
I might be able to do this!
Wait, I might be able to do this.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I can do this.
Ship.
Where's the entrance?
Come on, ship.
Where are you?
Oh, there it is!
I see it!
I can do
this.
Yes!
Yippee!
Um...
Anyway, uh...
Buckle up, buttercup, or...
Where else did I need... Oh, the quantum moon.
It's so cool just being here, though.
Are we that... Are we so close to the sun?
Um...
How do I view my map?
Oh.
No.
Oh, it's gonna take a while, isn't it?
The sun's getting pretty red.
Hmm.
Nice flying, Ace.
Thank you!
Um...
Oh, yeah.
We're like... Oh, we're like about...
We're halfway there!
Whoa!
Hmm...
You are in orbit.
Should we try again?
Since we're here?
Squidward on a chair!
I feel like it won't be so long.
I feel like if I go back...
Oh, I...
I might be able to do it.
I'm in orbit with the...
With the thing now, so...
Uh...
Hmm...
Is she doing the DLC?
Yes!
I might honestly give up.
If things are so...
If it takes too long...
If I'm so bad at it, I might give up.
I'll be honest.
But I don't want to give up.
Can I get you in there?
Can I just scoot you in real close?
Yeah.
There we go!
Nice!
Good la...
Ooh!
Snowflake!
Good landing!
Wait, how far... Oh, map.
Okay.
I'll wait till we're a little bit closer.
Probably.
Oh, get the Meditate too?
Okay, I'll get the Meditate too.
We'll have to go back to Giant's Deep then.
Hmm...
You can do it?
Thank you!
Look!
It's staying!
Wait, uh... Where do I need to...
Is around here good to stay?
Don't you go now!
Whoa!
I see you drifting!
This ain't no Initial D.
The other end.
Other side.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Oh!
Thank you guys for directing me.
Oh, where the red... where the red is.
Okay, okay.
For anybody coming in being like, Hey, this isn't the DLC.
That's because...
I had to start a new game.
And um...
Okay.
I think we're close, right?
Maybe not close enough.
Uh oh.
I had to start a new game.
But to get like the best ending of uh...
I passed it!
Oh, you know where it's at.
Look for the cracks in the rocky area.
Okay.
Cracks in the rocky area.
Oh!
It's starting to melt!
Oh no!
Uh oh.
Here?
Here.
We made it!
Uh oh.
Gosh.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh no.
This is where ghost matter is.
That looks like kind of ghost matter-y.
I'm just saying.
Oh no.
Not me.
And...
Take a snapshot.
Yep.
Okay.
This way!
Uh...
Oh!
Log, log, log!
Log, log, log.
Okay.
I'm receiving much stronger energy readings now that we're beneath the crust.
Whatever it is must lie somewhere below.
Closer to the comet's center.
And I'm starting to think it's more dangerous than we realized.
Clary, can you hear us?
Bye bye, ship.
It's okay.
We're gonna die here anyway.
Yes, but your voices are faint.
I fear we will lose communication entirely if you continue any deeper.
Keep the shuttle warm for us, Clary.
We'll return the moment we identify the source of the energy readings.
I understand, but be cautious, both of you.
Oh!
Oxygen!
Holy!
Okay.
Um...
Oops.
Uh... Where is the ghost matter at?
Oh, me!
So I can go down this one, right?
The ghost matter...
Yeah!
We can go down this one, right?
It's a winner!
Safe.
Let's go, baby.
But be careful.
Don't go too fast.
Avoid the ghost matter!
How do I...
How do I turn my flash... Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Now I think we have to go...
Oh!
Above?
Up and beyond?
I think?
Up?
I'm too scared.
I can't go down the...
Yeah, that's all ghost matter.
Oh, where... It's so hard...
to tell.
It's so hard to tell sometimes.
Maybe I should keep him up there.
That's the ghost matter hole.
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
You would think that a ghost like myself would be...
Look!
It even looks like me, doesn't it?
So funny.
Okay, how do I get...
I'm scared.
What if I fall into the hole?
What if I fall into the hole and die?
Okay.
Good job, team.
Any ghost matter around these parts?
Me?
No matter.
Every hole is a goal.
Where's the ghost matter?
Me?
Hidden matter.
See ya!
Oh.
Wait.
Oh!
I don't think I can go down there.
This way?
Or is this where I just came from?
Oh gosh.
Wait.
This looks...
This appears...
Yeah, this is where I just came from.
You have to choose the right path.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Ah!
Oh, scary, scary, scary, scary.
Okay, so I have to go right.
Left.
Okay, right.
I can't tell.
There's ghost matter in the bottom right-hand corner of the screen.
Ow!
There's the...
Whoa, we're so close to the center.
We might wanna use camera view for this.
Oh, how do I do that again?
Uh...
This one?
Launch mode?
Or...
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, we're gonna have to take this nice and easy, everybody.
Nice and easy.
But it was...
It was left first, right?
Oh gosh.
No, just kidding.
I'm too fast!
Okay, now...
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Keep going.
Slow and steady.
Any ghost matter?
Where?
Ah!
Dead body!
Um...
We did it!
Okay.
Is this a hole?
Uh...
Yes, it is.
I do believe so.
Okay.
Whoa.
I've played this before and even still I'm just like...
Wow!
Oh!
We can take it back.
Uh-oh.
Grab you.
Oh no!
Wait, wait, wait!
Stop, stop, stop, stop!
I'm trying to read it!
The spherical casing here...
Seems to be the source of the energy readings.
Can I please...
Take you back!
Okay.
There we go.
I'm so sorry.
I love physics.
Okay.
Guys, this is an emotional area, okay?
Wasn't there a button to stop time while reading?
That's what this is now, so...
The spherical stone casing here...
Seems to be the source of the energy readings.
No, rather the source of what's within the stone.
I'm detecting some form of exotic matter.
The stone is muting our energy readings.
They should be ten times what we're seeing at least.
Ugh, I just bit my tongue.
Pie, I don't think we want this matter interacting with us.
As far as I can tell, direct contact with it would almost certainly be fatal.
I've never encountered anything like this casing.
It's all...
But it's all that's protecting us from what's inside.
Worse still, this matter is disturbingly volatile.
I'm not sure if this is the right way to do it.
Pie, whatever the matter inside this stone casing is, it's more than just profoundly unstable.
It's under tons of pressure.
Look at this density scan.
I've never seen anything this tightly compacted before.
What is this?
Why are you guys sending tongues, huh?
Oh, because I bit my tongue.
This is orders of magnitude worse than I'd imagined.
If this stone were to rupture, the lethal matter within would rapidly expand.
Completely blanketing this star system almost instantaneously.
And the pressure is still building as the comet approaches the star system.
Return to the shuttle right now.
The rest of our friends need to know that they're in terrible danger.
Leave your equipment and run.
What are you doing, Pie?
The more we know about this alien matter, the better our chances of survival.
Survival.
I can't speak.
Sounds like it's about to bust.
But this thing's busting, man.
I will learn what I can do.
Go warn the others.
Maybe they can construct a shelter somehow.
Now, Poki!
All right.
So, we got this...
information.
I'm upside down.
Did I get everything in here, I think?
Can I...
Dang it, I missed.
Interloper?
Where did I come from?
Through that hole, I think?
Yeah.
It's so beautiful, though.
Oh, ghost matter.
Look at you.
Wait, there's a second hole.
That's a different hole.
Oh, I'm stuck.
That hole up there is a different hole.
Oh, that's probably a bad hole.
Ghost matter hole.
But I am going to die here anyway.
So...
We're beautiful and mysterious.
Dang.
Oh my gosh, that hole is full of me.
Hazard, hazard.
Oh no, are you okay?
I guess we'll just wait it out until we...
Until 60 seconds left, everybody.
Oh, we're by the sun again.
Never mind.
I didn't think that it went into the sun.
Okay.
The Quantum Moon, though, I imagine...
is going to have a lot of stuff that...
You know what I mean?
Because there's all the different...
There's the Bramble Moon...
and there's like the...
There's a lot of stuff...
Wait, I have to go back to the...
Frozen Nomai shuttle?
Or did I get everything that will be...
needed for the...
For the DLC?
But you already have the knowledge.
Yeah, but apparently if you have it...
in your logs...
then there's a different...
a slightly different outcome...
of the game.
You got everything needed?
Okay, cool.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Got what you needed from the interloper.
Awesome.
Um...
That's enough knowledge for that part.
Thanks, Jeffrey!
Sucks that I had to...
do a whole new game.
Then I'm wasting a little bit of time.
But that's okay, because I...
just enjoy going around...
so much in this.
So, let's go find ourselves a...
Quantum Moon!
So, don't...
go to the sun.
Where would... If I were a Quantum Moon...
That's not it.
No, that's Idle Rock.
If I were a Quantum Moon...
I'd be right there.
Little recap.
Yeah, this is good though.
Okay, so with this...
I have to take a picture of you.
Don't go into him.
Don't fly in!
Don't touch!
Okay.
Wait.
How do I...
Um...
Unbuckle.
Photo mode.
Say cheese!
Cheese!
Okay.
Now I can buckle back...
Wait.
Oh.
Okay.
Oopsie!
Let's check our map.
If I were a Quantum Moon...
Where would I be?
If I...
Oh, wait.
I just saw the...
Like that other rotation.
It looks like for the DLC.
Wait.
Is that...
Power Glass Twins?
Um...
Will it show up on here?
Ah!
No!
Why are you at the Bramble?
Well, I might have moved by now, actually.
Where is the Bramble?
Can I look at my map from here?
Okay.
You know what?
Good.
It left the Bramble.
Where are you now?
The Bramble.
Are you at Giant's Seat?
Maybe...
No...
If I were...
Where are you?
Am I blind?
It will keep moving.
You gotta find it on...
Oh!
Will it... If I lock on...
Will it keep...
I think I have to go actually look for it.
Ah!
Oh!
I found it.
Stop doubting my abilities.
Okay.
So I can't go in with my ship.
I'm really close to the sun though.
I'm kind of scared.
I'm real close to the...
I'm real close to the sun.
Oh!
I'm glad that doesn't count as...
Okay.
Photo mode.
Take a snapshot.
Why?
Where are you going?
You can enter on your ship.
Wait.
How do I...
Okay.
You guys might need to backseat me a little bit more.
Cause I'm... I'm confused.
Your ship has a camera.
It does!
There it goes.
Launch the ship.
Okay.
Well it's gone now.
So...
Let's figure out where it went this time.
We got this.
So I...
Launched the scouter on my ship.
And then it should be good.
There.
Perfect.
Perfect!
Okay.
It's the exact same controls as the scout launcher.
Thank you guys.
Sorry.
It's been a minute.
Okay.
I appreciate you being patient with me.
This is good too though.
Because I'll remember how to do stuff.
For the DLC too.
So now...
Did that take a picture?
I think that's it.
In there, right?
So...
Is that it?
Now I'm good?
So now I can go in?
Here I go.
Full speed!
Okay.
Now I have to remember...
So I said some...
Don't do certain things here.
Right?
They were like...
Don't go to certain areas.
Whoa!
So scary!
Wait.
It's Y, right?
Do not jump.
Where do you think you're going?
I have to find that one building.
Go north?
Okay.
This... This way.
Wait.
The ship's fine, everybody!
The ship's fine!
Quantum ship.
Oh!
Hello!
Wait.
We're fine.
Find the tower.
Oh!
There!
Is that it?
Nope.
That's just a really thick tree.
Yeah, I'm looking for the tower now.
Because I know that's where we have to go.
Did I like land in the worst possible place?
Is that even possible?
It's so scary here.
I'm so excited for the DLC.
Oh!
There it is!
Perfect.
Now one thing I don't remember...
One thing I don't remember...
Oh, I have to be in this spot, right?
It has to be in the secret spot?
Yep.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh, let's grab this stuff too, just in case.
Okay.
Very nice.
Alright.
We turn out the lights.
And we are...
Not there.
Can I turn on my flashlight?
There!
This looks complicated.
Oh.
The shrine has to be at the North Pole.
Oh, shoot.
How do I...
Oh, sure, the...
You have to be at the North Pole first.
Oh, no.
Wait, so I have to go to the North Pole?
North Pole before teleporting there.
Oh, you have to leave the tower in different planets.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Let's open.
Let's try here.
Wait, I'm scared.
Isn't this the Bramble World?
Oh, yes.
Because we can't always get to the North Pole.
But we can here.
Perhaps.
Maybe.
Okay.
Scary, scary, scary.
Hope there's no fish around.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's all coming back to me slowly but surely.
Slowly but surely.
Actually, does this work?
I don't think it does.
I don't think this...
I don't think this does work.
We're not entirely at the North Pole.
We're like mostly at the North Pole.
Made it further.
Oh, I don't know why I always turn the lights on.
I have my flashlight.
Okay.
Maybe here?
Does not...
Wait.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Oh, wait.
Not here.
Not quite.
Wait, I got it?
What do you mean I got it?
Oh, this works?
For real?
Oh, hello.
Oh, goodbye.
Just spin?
Oh, okay.
Cool.
I'm spinning.
Spinning all around.
Ah!
Yippee!
Okay.
Thanks, guys, for your help.
Really, truly appreciate you guys.
Thank you.
First try, baby.
We're here.
And...
We gotta go talk to somebody.
Speedrun.
For real, right?
This game is so spooky.
Hits every good beat.
Am I going the wrong way?
Oh, wait.
Do I go into the hole?
Oh, I can't remember.
You're going right?
Wait.
I go into the hole and...
Do not go into the hole.
Okay.
Not yet.
Where...
Where is she?
Not yet.
Okay.
Is she close to the hole?
Found her.
Wow!
How are you?
Oh!
That's right.
Okay.
This is a lot.
I remember all this.
There's, like, so many things that we're gonna have to, like, mix and match and talk to about.
Do you guys mind if I, um...
I don't wanna skip through it.
But...
Where do I put it?
Oh, thank you.
We've heard it before.
It's okay.
It's so cool, though.
It's so awesome.
Have you encountered a quantum shard on another planet?
The shards look the same as the quantum moon's surface does now, while at the eye.
From this, we can reasonably infer the quantum moon's natural state is as we see it now, and that the eye is its primary location.
Okay.
I am gonna skip a little bit through it.
Ship log updated.
Okay.
We updated one thing.
We're, like...
It's so funny.
I've done nothing, but we're in endgame.
Okay.
Find the eye.
I'm unsure how you arrived here.
Yes, yes, yes.
Very good.
Speed lore.
Fundamental uncertainty throughout the universe.
The eye.
Oh my gosh.
Can't wait to do more about the eye.
Quantum moon probably exhibits macroscopic quantum behavior because of its proximity to the eye.
Blah, blah, blah.
And then your clan died.
So sad.
But it's not from the eye.
It's from the ghost matter.
I am on my first pilgrimage to the quantum moon.
All know Maya and my clan make this journey when we come of age.
This goes so crazy.
I will be so scared.
Okay.
Now we switch it out.
From explanation to identify stone.
Okey dokey.
Identify me.
Solanumbus girl.
Never met one of your kind before.
It's an honor to speak with you.
I particularly admire your four eyes.
You call me a nerd?
Hey there, four eyes.
There are many questions I would ask if I could comprehend your language.
You have my gratitude for understanding mine.
What if I didn't understand it?
What if I just was like...
Stop using that emote.
This is the quantum moon.
Where we are both standing.
Despite also orbiting other celestial bodies, the quantum moon is the eye of the universe's moon.
Oh my brain.
I forgot how much this was like.
This game makes my brain go...
I am Solanum.
Anomai.
My clan arrived in this star system before my birth and we now call it home.
Yes, they were searching for the eye and they ended up in the bramble.
Right?
And then they all went to like the different planets and kind of set up base there but then the interloper caused them to all die.
Why you don't have a nerd emote?
What are you talking about?
My otaku...
My otaku emote is the nerd emote.
Sorry, I am eating my dinner.
You can make stones of the same color?
You can?
We are orbiting the eye of the universe now.
Although we cannot see it.
Only the quantum moon's reflection of it.
The eye is older than the universe itself and my clan believes it dwells in an extremely distant orbit around this solar system.
Otaku.
Suppose... suppose you could reach the eye of the universe.
Would you try to enter it?
What do you imagine the effects of a conscious observer might be?
Freaky.
So freaky.
Hey Mint, hello!
Imagine you've noticed the quantum moon changes in appearance depending on which location it is currently orbiting.
For instance, yes.
So we knew that, but because the quantum moon clearly changes in its different forms, the eye in this moon's primary location must be similarly malleable.
From this we can hypothesize that the eye represents extreme changeability.
That said, despite its malleable nature, the quantum moon becomes locked to one specific version of itself when it is consciously observed.
But what would happen if a conscious observer were to enter the eye?
Wait, which ones have I been switching out?
Oh shoot.
Wait.
I don't... this one, right?
This one.
Right?
I think so.
Okay.
Give me more text!
Speak!
Speak you!
Like many of the clan before me, I journeyed here to see the quantum moon's reflection of the eye.
This is the closest any of us have come to seeing the eye itself.
You may think I'm strange, but I have a hypothesis that I may not be entirely alive.
Perhaps my journey has reached its end.
Oh, shiplock.
Okay, good, good, good, good.
Say it, don't spry it.
Oh, I swapped the other one?
Oh.
It's okay.
Cause, uh...
I'm just gonna get all of them cause I don't know what we need and what we don't need.
Kao!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Is this your first time on the quantum moon?
It's my first time here.
If you've come here looking for answers, I hope you find them.
Oof.
I'm left with so many questions.
Did I do this one?
I like dropping them on the floor to keep track.
That's a good idea.
Okay.
We'll put that there then.
But it looks so pretty up on there, right?
Up on the wall instead?
Okay, we've gotten this one.
Uh, we probably haven't done this one and this one, right?
You.
You!
Many of my clan have believed the eye called to us for a particular purpose.
When I was a child, I used to believe the eye was malevolent.
To have lured my clan to the star system only to then vanish from them so completely.
But I don't fear the eye anymore.
In fact, it became my fondest hope to see the eye itself someday.
But I fear this may be beyond my reach.
You may think I'm strange, but I have a hypothesis.
That I may not...
Oh.
Okay.
Yes.
Maybe I got all of them now.
Just kidding.
We do not have much connection, you and I.
Still, this encounter feels special.
I hope you won't mind if I think of you as a friend.
My friend!
An eye-pothesis?
Oh!
Okay.
I think we got everything now.
Maybe.
Hopefully.
Yes.
Oh, my brain is hurting.
From which ones I've put up here and which ones I haven't.
It's my birthday!
Chaotic's so happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Chaotic Snow.
Okay.
Now I think we've gotten all of them.
Probably.
I think so.
What if I do these two?
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, it worked.
These are the two tenets of Nomai philosophy.
To seek out and to understand is our way of living.
Oh.
Okay.
Nerds.
I think that's actually...
I'm too paranoid.
Okay.
Let's do it all over again, I suppose.
I think you got it with the last log update.
Okay.
I'm just doing one last check.
You can fly into the eye shadow to find the quantum shuttle if you want.
There's an additional scene if you can visit if you can get to wait, can get if you visit the ship mural in Brittle Hollow.
Oh, okay.
Last thing to do is visit the mural in the vessel in the black hole planet or visit the vessel in Bramble.
You should totally visit Bramble.
Wait, is it Brittle Hollow or Bramble?
Wait, vessel in the black hole planet.
Oh, either one?
Brittle Bramble?
Vessel is in the Bramble.
You just need to know what happened to the vessel.
Both works but the vessel takes longer.
Brittle Hollow is easier.
Wait.
I don't quite remember where it is.
I think I've got all of these.
Now, let's not make a mess.
Let's clean up our...
Nice.
Let's clean up our mess.
Made in action.
It's in my DNA!
If I even have that anymore.
Go to the mural in the vessel at the black hole inside of the Bramble.
Oh.
I think it's time.
Wait.
Solanum!
Wait!
No!
You have to...
You can escape with me!
Come on!
Just hop on my ship!
Thank you for the...
This is a red...
As the sun...
There's a special ending here?
Really?
Oh my gosh.
Hug it out.
So close.
So cute.
You...
You're so close.
Hold on.
I'm gonna get a picture of the two of us.
Wait.
Launch it.
Oh.
Get it closer.
A little closer.
Yay!
One second.
I'll read your Akasupa in just a second.
Friends.
Just the two of us.
We can make it if we try.
Just the...
Two of us.
You and I.
Our last memory.
So cute.
Lots of...
Lots of quantum stuff.
I did talk to Gabriel.
I have to go talk to him again.
Thank you for reminding me.
Yes, because I was recommended to get the...
Give me one second.
I was recommended to get the Meditate.
As is the sun.
You hear that music?
The end times have come.
Why is it so sad?
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Yeah, we gotta go talk to...
Garbo.
No, his name is Gabro.
Okay.
So, I should go talk to him.
And I should go...
To... wait.
Bramble or Brittle Hollow?
I don't wanna go to...
I'm scared of Brittle Hollow.
Where is...
Where are we going?
Um...
Quantum Moon.
Brittle Hollow?
Is easier?
Okay.
Where are you?
There you are!
Giant's Deep is kind of a pain in the butt to get around though.
Because it's so gravity heavy.
I think you can do Brittle and Gabro in the same loop.
That's what I'm gonna try.
I'm gonna try.
I'm gonna...
There will be an attempt.
Alright.
Go on in, baby!
Okay.
Meow.
Oh, learning...
Ow!
Okay.
It ends the loop if I learn the meditation?
Uh-oh.
Where is he?
Oh my goodness.
I hope he wasn't there.
Because he sure is gone now.
Oh, there he is.
Oh!
Whoops!
Ah, it's fine.
As long as I can get out.
Unbuckle.
Nice.
Out!
Oh, there he is.
All good, everybody.
I was hoping you'd be back.
Something really weird is going on.
You think we're in a time loop?
Definitely in a time loop.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Cool.
What do you think it was?
I figured it'd be some kind of fidgety time business, but I wasn't really thinking about what's happening to the shape of time, you know?
But a loop makes sense here.
Let's go with loop for now.
So it looks like you and I are the only ones who know we're in a time loop.
And even if you tell them about it, no one remembers by the next loop.
What's with that?
Maybe it's because we both made some seriously intense eye contact with a Nomai statue.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
I found something?
Uh...
My time buddy's back.
Wait...
Oh...
I have to come back on the next loop.
Okay.
You have to unlock...
Visit him twice.
Dang!
That's okay.
Let's fix the ship.
Oh...
Uh...
Let's fix the ship.
And then...
We'll head over...
Oh, can I even get up there?
Uh-oh.
Let's wait until we go into outer space.
Uh...
We might be going into outer space like right now.
Beam me up, Scotty!
Right here!
Right now!
Here we go!
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go!
Wait!
Oh, God.
No, no, no, no.
Up, up, up, up.
Okay.
I'm a genius.
I'm a genius, everybody.
Okay.
Buckle up.
And let's leave.
Perfect.
Perfect execution.
We only have a few cracks on our screen.
Okay, not there.
Um...
Uh-oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're coming in high.
We're coming in a little bit high there.
There it is.
I have no idea where to go, though.
Truthfully, I have no idea where to go for this mural.
Did you drop your phone?
Nice crosshair.
It's near the drop.
Look for the escape pod.
Look for the beacon.
Try to land near the escape pod.
I don't remember.
I don't remember where that is.
Emergency beacon.
Okay, I'm looking for a beacon.
Use the signal scope.
Okay.
To locate the emergency beacon.
Thank you.
That's what we shall try to do.
Unless it's...
No, that's the launcher.
Right there.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
We came in hot, hot.
Oh, dang.
There we go.
Nice.
That was probably the best landing I think I've ever done in my career.
That was probably the absolute best landing I've ever done ever.
That's pretty impressive.
I would say.
Nice.
Okay, let's not die.
Alright.
Signal scope.
That's not it.
But that's all.
No.
Change the frequency?
That?
Might be good to go visit our banjo friend though for some oxygen.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, that's the quantum rock?
What does it sound like instead?
Museum shard.
Haha.
What?
Oh my goodness.
Why am I so bad at this?
What?
Why am I so...
Uh...
Change the frequency.
Oh no, I don't think I have it.
Oh no, I don't think I have the frequency.
Uh oh.
Oh shoot.
We're just gonna...
go around and...
Oh wait, we can get some oxygen here.
And some fuel and stuff.
That'll be good.
Guess we zoom.
We just gotta find the mural, right?
We just gotta get to the mural.
Where is your oxygen?
Ouch.
Didn't mean to go down so hard.
Or your fuel I meant.
I keep... I think I keep saying oxygen.
What the heck is that?
Space egg.
Where's your fuel?
Is there none here?
Okay.
Let's just keep moving then.
Okay, I'm gonna go along the equator.
I think we can do it.
If not, um...
That's okay though.
Boom, boom, boom.
This is the cannon.
Searching my ship is probably faster.
Yeah, but did you see that landing?
It's fine.
It didn't take us that long to get to Gabbro and...
You know.
We're getting more oxygen.
It's all good, baby.
But after this I will...
Well, I gotta get to meditate.
And then we'll do the DLC.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Maybe I should have just played on my other account.
Wait, is that it?
Do I see it with my...
eyes?
I believe!
But this has been a great way to kind of reintroduce myself back to the...
Back to the game.
Okay, so down here, right?
Uh-oh.
I don't have much fuel.
Follow the platforms below.
Okay.
Uh, how do I get...
to the platform?
Which is a great question.
I know these drop.
Like, some of them break down, you know?
So I'm kind of nervous to just drop down.
Okay.
Please don't break!
Ah!
Okay.
We're fine!
Everything's fine!
Made it!
Okay.
This way.
Let's keep going.
Where do I go from here?
Mural should be in the lower section of here.
So, like...
Oh gosh.
I don't wanna go...
I don't wanna go into the...
To the black hole.
Down here, maybe?
Everybody backseating?
Thank you.
Maybe I shouldn't even say backseating.
You're just helping.
Drop below here.
Okay.
Oh no!
Oh no, I can't make it in.
Oh gosh.
Uh...
Why are you sideways?
So I have to go in here.
Oh, I see it.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Um... I'm gonna grab this too.
Just in case.
How do I get down there?
You can just walk around.
I can.
Like so?
If I drop down here?
Will I make it?
Or...
Oh...
Okay.
Risking it for the biscuit.
I guess.
Ouch!
We're fine!
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Why did the vessel crash in that place?
Mm-hmm.
Was the vessel unwell?
Probably not the vessel, but the destination.
I'm afraid for our friends in escape pod 3.
And...
Yippee!
Okay.
And we get all these too.
Okay, good, good, good.
Alright.
Vessel...
It's for I.
Vessel trapped in Bramble.
Escape from Bramble.
To other planets.
Nice little summary.
Okay.
DLC start-o!
Lore get!
Yay!
Thank you guys!
Thank you for your patience!
Thank you for helping me out!
Um... We're gonna do one more.
Look at my ship.
I love this view.
Tori!
Welcome to Mambooship.
Very cool!
We're gonna do one last loop.
Because we're gonna get meditate.
And then we shall go for the...
DLC.
Thank you for the summary, boss.
Of course!
Don't thank me.
I'm just gonna die in space.
We'll have no fuel.
How close can I get to the sun?
Openly discussing a backstage in a game like this for a bit has been an unusual experience, but also fun.
It is weird for me too because usually I'd be like No no no don't tell me anything But it's all stuff that I've experienced before so it's just kind of like...
whatever.
You know.
It's just kind of whatever.
Whatever.
It's just getting it so that we can proceed forward.
You will hit the sun before you run out of oxygen?
Perfect.
Will we though?
I'm almost out of fuel.
But maybe I have enough...
Maybe I have enough momentum to launch me.
Into the sun!
Here we go.
Everybody shield your eyes.
It's so bright.
I'm touching grass!
Perfect.
Nice.
Okay.
To you.
Yes, my love.
Don't go anywhere.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Stay with me.
I'm gonna go grab that meditator.
It's so crazy how like you could literally just...
speedrun this game.
If you just know where to go.
If you know the secret of the Quantum Moon, you can be like...
Yeah.
Oh, there it is!
Hey, Quantum Moon.
Bye, Quantum Moon.
Current record is like six minutes.
That's crazy.
Wowee.
Oh, there he is.
Perfect.
Land.
Oh, not in the trees again.
Come on.
Don't do this to me.
Okay.
Perfect.
Great landing.
Give me the meditator, man.
They also run it shipless?
Is that even possible?
How do you get out of... How do you get off of Timberhurst?
My time, buddy.
How do you stay so calm in the face of repeating and ending death?
Deep breaths.
Seriously, I meditate.
Want me to teach you?
Sure.
Close your eyes.
Ah, here we go.
Physics?
Wait until you find out about suitless.
What?
That doesn't seem possible.
Oh my god.
An hour and thirty minutes into the stream and we're finally getting to the DLC, baby.
Okay, let's go find that radio tower.
Which I'm just going to use the spaceship.
Hmm.
I'm just using the spaceship.
There's a geyser.
And why is this planet so flat?
Besides, like, some mountains and...
Let's see.
I have such a delicate touch, don't I?
Being able to fly so... easy.
Oh.
Wait.
Is this it?
No.
This is...
What's up there?
It's a tree, boss?
Okay.
What are you saying?
What does that mean?
Okay.
I think I remember this forest.
It has like...
There's like one forest where the trees are also kind of quantum-y.
If I were a radio tower...
You'd think it would be way easier to see.
Maybe I should go into space a little bit more.
Wait.
Aha!
I'm sideways.
It's good landing.
No panic at all.
The quantum grove, yeah.
Yeah, it's pretty freaky in there.
Hello!
Hello, hello!
I've seen that before.
And we're recording!
Ahem!
It's been two days since the launch of the Deep Space Satellite, and I'm about to view the first batch of photos.
Let the record show that on this historic day, Outer Wilds Ventures has...
Ah!
They're printing!
Here they come!
Stars above, will you look at that!
There's Brittle Hollow!
And look, look there!
That's Hollow's Lantern!
And there's Giant's Deep!
And... and the Quantum Moon!
I'm speechless.
Completely speechless!
Every single astral body... wait, if we had a picture of Quantum Moon this whole time, why is it still moving around?
Every single astral body in our magnificent solar system, looking stunning from every angle in each of these three images.
Because nobody was looking at the picture.
Oh, I guess that's fair.
And in color, no less.
Now this is art.
I could stare at these photos forever.
Doesn't Timber Hearth look tiny from?
Hold on.
What is that?
That can't be right.
That's... I mean, that's not even possible.
Am I interrupting this... oh, inter... interpreting this photo correctly?
What's even stranger is, it doesn't show up in either of the other photos.
Just this one.
Well, there must have been an equipment malfunction, I suppose.
Only sensible explanation for it.
I'll radio Gabbro and ask them to go examine the satellite's lens for defects.
Oh god, he scared me again.
Wait, something... that doesn't show up?
That only shows up in one of them.
Only... something that only shows up in one of them.
Besides Gabbro.
That's... Timber Hearth.
No, that's Tim... wait, no, yeah, that's Brittle Hollow.
That's Timber Hearth.
Huh?
Hearth, there's a secret scene if you go bramble and touch fish.
I'm... not fish.
Is true.
Sorry for... you're okay.
It only shows up in one of the... okay, so we... okay, our first puzzle, everybody!
Woohoo!
Is it... that?
Little dot?
Yeah, it's not... he... is it...
And that's Timber Hearth, so...
That tiny little dot?
That's your crosshair?
No!
How... I wish I could observe it more closely.
There's the... yeah, cause there's the Quantum Moon.
And it's not here.
Cause this is Timber Hearth.
And that's our... that's Attle Rock.
And that's us, Attle Rock.
It's the only thing that I can see different.
Where's my ship?
Uh-oh.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I'm gonna put on my suit and see if anything changes when I put it on.
Hold on.
Okay.
A rapidly white dot.
Yeah, totally.
Okay.
I see you guys smiling.
No spoilers, no hints, no nothing.
20 meters?
Deep Space Radio.
Oh.
Neat.
What is that?
Is it a quantum thing so I have to take a picture and observe it?
Why is it so dark there?
There's Quantum Moon.
Oh my gosh.
That's Attle Rock.
That's brittle.
That's...
Hi, Quantum Moon.
It's always so fun to say hello to the Quantum Moon.
I don't know why.
Wait, so...
Gabbro will always be spoopy.
It's true.
It's gotta be that, right?
Because it's the only thing that seems different in all these photos.
Just that tiny... I wish I could, like, zoom in.
Come on, scoot down.
What is that thing?
It looks kind of like a jellyfish.
I don't see it there.
I know this solar system like the back of my hand.
I've never seen a third thing circulating our planet.
And...
It's not the Quantum Moon either.
Even though I don't see where the Quantum Moon is here.
Push a zoom button?
There's a zoom button?
Zoom?
Oh, the signal scope.
It's so pixely.
It's just a little...
It's just a little dot.
It looks like dirt.
Are you sure you know it like the back of your hand?
I think so.
Right?
Deep space radio.
Is there any other deep space frequencies that I should be aware of?
Quantum fluctuations.
Hello quantum moon.
You're listening to deep space radio.
Does the angle matter?
I'm going to take another picture of it.
Maybe I must launch into space to find such a mysterious thing around us.
I can whistle pretty well, can't I?
I think I just learned that about myself.
If you ever need another whistler, Jeffrey, I'm your ghost.
Wait, if I buckle up, I'm going to lose the picture.
I was like, what's that flashing?
You're pretty good.
Where are you
at?
It's mysterious.
Other...
presents?
What could you be?
Where are you at?
My eyes.
Oh my god.
I like watching the media go backwards.
It's so funny.
Sun's looking angry.
No, we still have time.
If I just follow Attle Rock, will I eventually...
That's what it's called, right?
I'm not just saying names, am I?
What if I go to the observatory?
...
Okay, I'm correct.
Okay.
Oh, finally.
Where did the shade come from?
Wait, I think I just saw the sun station.
It's so crazy that you could see everything from this...
from, like...
It's so crazy.
It blows my mind that I can, like, travel this universe, this solar system, but also see it almost entirely from my...
from my home planet.
It's so awesome.
Like, I can just look up into space and be like, oh!
There's those planets!
I'm moving at the same velocity as them.
Almost.
What's over here?
This game is beautifully designed.
Yeah, it really is.
Okay, definitely not that.
Oh, hi Quantum Moon!
Oh!
I remember this is where one of the Brittles...
fell in.
That doesn't...
What?
Where am I supposed to find this thing?
Maybe I do need to go back to my ship.
This way.
Maybe I do need to fly around in my ship.
Bramble, scramble!
Okay, addle rock.
Let's try going to addle rock, I suppose.
And seeing from there.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, the bramble in the distance.
It's just so cool, right?
It's just so awesome.
I could be like, oh, a little bramble.
Alrighty.
This puzzle is already scratching my brain.
Psst!
Okay.
Buckle up, buttercup.
What the?
Has there always been a teleporter here?
Is it usable?
There has?
Oh!
Blind.
I remember going inside there.
Okay.
Addle rock.
Have you checked your ship's logs?
No.
Should I?
Ouch.
Not bad.
We're fine.
Why did I get hurt?
Let's see.
Quantum moon.
Quantum shrine.
Sixth location.
Old settlement.
The vessel.
Mural.
Escape pod.
Radio tower.
Hmm.
What am I eating?
A taco bowl.
Hahaha.
It's my dinner.
Remember to wear your seatbelt, Chad, or that could be you.
Hahaha.
Hmm.
A radio tower designed to receive photos taken by the deep space satellite.
There are several photos of the entire solar system hanging on the walls.
Horned fowls noticed something strange in one of the photos.
But concluding the equipment malfunction was the only sensible explanation.
I wonder if I go talk to him.
If I'm like, hey, mister.
Horned fowls.
Alright.
We're looking for addle rock.
Or horned fowls.
Whichever we find sooner.
He's at the observatory, correct?
Oh my gosh, I had like a little...
I have like a spot I just noticed on my monitor that I need to clean.
And I was like, is that it?
Hahaha.
What the?
What is this?
Oh, excuse me!
Excuse me!
Oh, it's going inside.
It's not going inside.
It's...
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm coming in!
Did it just go inside here?
Wait, where did it go?
I lost... oh, there it is.
What is this thing?
That was so close, wasn't it?
Hahaha.
What is this thing?
I can't... I can't...
It won't let me like, lock on it.
It's the planet's satellite.
Oh.
It's been here the whole time?
It's for the probe of the Nomai.
Hahaha.
I was like, I found it!
I was so excited, you guys, man.
From the probe tutorial.
Dang.
Okay.
Where is Adel... I think we...
I saw Adelrock and I ignored it, because I was just like, not...
You're not my little tiny satellite?
Okay, this is where the brambles.
Adelrock.
Oh.
Wait.
Pashamin!
Hello!
Good landing.
And Dark Skies, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Unidentified...
Wow!
I'm about to...
Set myself on fire, man.
Quantum moon!
Uh -oh.
The sun is looking...
It's pretty spicy.
Hello!
Press expert.
Hahaha.
Hey, this ain't my first rodeo, man.
I don't need no...
I don't need no landing mode.
Hahaha.
Okay, where is...
Oh, here we go.
I see...
That's not it.
That looks like another thing that exploded in space.
Maybe I should talk to him anyway.
Hey, it's you!
Ground control didn't tell me you were launching.
Long time no see.
Actually, I guess it's been a long time since I've seen anyone.
What is that you're whistling?
I thought it was like, whistling.
Probably.
Or actually, definitely.
The other travelers carry instruments.
So they don't bother whistling.
You can pick up their music with the signal scope.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
Okay.
It's some...
I wish I still had the photo.
To get the angle.
It's time.
For the meatball.
Wow.
It's like a mouth.
I...
I'm gonna go look at the photo again.
07s in the chat, everybody.
07s.
Or I can just be in orbit.
While we die.
Oh, there's...
There's an observatory.
We'll just stay in orbit, I guess.
While we die.
You could just meditate through this.
I guess you're right.
It's kind of awesome.
Being in orbit, though.
I'm a...
I'm a moon now.
I'm a moon!
This music is always a combination of sad plus jumbled.
You can kind of hear it in the beginning, though.
It's not quite...
It's a little less of a jump scare.
There we go.
Gosh, could you take any longer to explode?
Come on, son.
Okay.
Let's go take another look at the picture.
And see if I can notice any...
Any defining features...
Of the picture.
That will help me find it.
Hmm.
Okay.
How's my little ghost matter doing?
Don't call me that!
It seems gross.
I don't like it.
Don't call me that!
Okay.
I am on the right track, though, right?
Like, that's the thing that...
Oh.
That's the thing that I'm looking for.
Right?
You're cooking.
Okay.
I'm gonna cover myself...
With ghost matter.
Takodachi, you okay?
What, do I have to go all the way to, like, the black hole station?
It shouldn't have to be like that, right?
Deep space signal.
Okay.
Deep space radio.
Oh!
Wait a second.
It didn't show up before.
So I was like...
It doesn't exist.
Oh.
Wait, it disappeared.
Oh, no.
It's still there.
Autopilot!
Here we go!
I think I remember seeing this red dot before.
And questioning it.
Before in the actual game.
It's kind of far.
It's actually quite far.
How am I so close?
But it looks so far away.
Oh?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
Coming in hot!
What the heck is this?
Oh, it's a satellite.
Um...
Error.
Offline.
Is that what it said?
And there's a radio.
Okay, we gotta get out.
Okay.
I gotta get in there.
Where is it?
There!
Oh shoot.
Oh!
Hold!
Wait!
There
we go.
Wait.
Gabbro here.
Checking in on the Deep Space Satellite.
Per Ground Control's request to check out a possible equipment problem.
See, Hornfels?
I do to work.
You know, I wouldn't mind being a satellite.
See?
He gets it!
That's what we were doing.
It's peaceful out here.
Among the distant stars and the soft, velvety darkness.
But it's...
Gosh, I actually really are...
awfully nice for naps too.
Alright, the lens.
Alright, little satellite.
Let's see what the trouble is.
Huh.
Everything looks A-OK.
Ground Control, no dust or scratches on the lens, and no evidence of sparking or violent explosions.
Guess that rules out an equipment malfunction after all.
When you drive, you also hit the gas before you know which direction you're supposed to be pointed.
Sometimes I do just go.
Also, shut the hell up, Murphy.
I kicked your ass once, I'll do it again.
Hear that, pal?
You're in great shape.
Keep up the good work out here.
My ship is so far.
OK.
Nice and easy.
Easy peasy.
Error.
Map offline.
OK.
And...
What does that mean?
Outer Wild Adventures.
Uh-huh.
Um...
You bonked it?
Bonk.
...
... Where's our planet?
Oh.
Timber.
My ship.
Where'd it go?
Oh my god.
Can't ever find the same thing.
Is there anything else I need to...
Hmm.
Uh...
Bonk!
Um...
Let's go back to my ship.
OK.
Uh...
...
The silence with only your breath against the helmet...
I know!
It makes me want to be so quiet, right?
Makes me...
It makes me not want to... I'm like...
You know?
Oh, please.
Please.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up!
...
Well, what did that teach me?
That didn't teach me so much, though.
...
We didn't even get, like, a little entry about the satellite.
Hmm.
Not to bonk satellites.
What?
What's wrong with bonking the satellite?
...
Oh?
Uh-oh.
Did I break it?
...
But it was already broken!
Uh, maybe I should go home.
...
Where is home?
Oh, now I actually don't know.
I was gonna... Okay, there we go.
I was like...
Only because you bonked it.
Wait, really?
Uh-oh.
...
Gabbro said it was fine.
No, when I came up on it, it said it was map offline!
...
When I came up on it!
Before I even touched it!
...
I promise!
I saw it!
...
Am I the body?
Oopsie.
...
Um...
Oh no.
Wait.
If I go to...
If I go to him, can I be like...
I'm really sorry I broke the thing.
Will he be mad at me?
...
I broke the map.
I broke the map!
...
He will kill you.
Alex, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
...
Hello, Quantum Stone.
I did it.
I broke the map.
...
He doesn't care!
Okay.
...
Let's go...
Let's go back to...
...
This is the...
This is the satellite we just went to.
And broke.
...
I guess.
Allegedly.
There's no evidence of me breaking it.
...
Okay.
These balls move on their own!
...
I need to get back up to my ship.
Perfect.
...
I think I'm...
I think I'm stuck.
Let's see.
Hold on.
Is it... Ow.
Maybe under the map view.
...
What's this?
Oh, Quantum Moon.
...
What's this?
Ash Twin.
...
I'm starting to realize why she has DVR turned off.
Let's go back to the...
...
To the radio tower.
Just solve it.
...
Just solve it, forehead.
I didn't see it either...
Oh my gosh.
Scared me again.
I didn't see it either when I went out there.
...
Do I have to wait for these planets to be in this alignment?
That's so much though.
...
Did she find the DLC yet, chat?
Go back to the second photo and count the planets.
Wait, what's the second photo?
...
This one?
Oh,
advance.
...
5, 6.
1...
2...
3...
Oh my god, this scared me.
4...
5, 6.
Am I...
missing something?
1...
2...
3...
4...
5, 6...
7!
It's you!
Well, I thought this was strange, but I thought it was... actually...
Timber Hearth is right there.
I'm the dummy.
I noticed it this whole time, but I thought it was Timber Hearth that's eclipsing the sun.
Oh.
Whoopsie.
Because it... oh, it's in this picture that it's eclipsing the sun.
Ah, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Oh, wait, but...
Uh?
It's a coffee stain.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
So then...
Satellite angle 40.
Common Outer Wilds occurrence.
You should see playtest with no chat.
I can't even imagine.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Satellite angle 40.
Gabbro.
Hmm...
Do I have to go back to the satellite?
Or is it now, anyway?
Where are you?
Where are you, other satellite?
Okay, so it's not even picking up anymore.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Um...
It's not even picking up anymore.
See, this is why I couldn't find it in the first place.
Hmm...
What is here?
Despite my checking on them a thousand times over, the images are still not ready to print over in the radio tower.
Oh.
Now they are.
Gabbro's three foolproof steps for dozing off.
Oh, I dozed off.
My bad.
I pressed the wrong button.
There we go.
Ha.
Ah!
You can find the satellite using the map.
The one, the map that I broke?
You mean the map that I broke?
Okay, I'm gonna meditate.
Oop.
Let's just meditate, I guess.
Goodbye, everybody.
Looping again.
Hmm...
Sorry, watching it spin like that was so sweet.
Okay.
Okey-dokey.
The launch couch.
I hope she breaks it again.
Stop it!
Whoa, what the heck was that?
Gosh, there's some aliens on this planet.
Or in this...
This one.
Hmm...
That's the interloper.
Don't bonk it this time.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Gonna do my best.
No promises.
Where is it anyway?
Okay.
I'm not gonna bonk it.
I'm not...
Why is it...
It's...
It's actually the satellite's fault for being such a sensitive baby.
Okay.
Watch her bonk it.
I'm not gonna bonk it.
I'm not even gonna get close to it.
Okay, that's a little close.
Okay.
It's in its orbit.
It's totally doing its thing.
I'm going behind it.
To see what it sees.
Okay.
It's just like a sensitive baby is all, you know?
It's a good thing that I moved.
I'm getting out.
Satellite!
I come in peace!
I come with no ill intentions.
Yup, I think you got something that I might need.
Angle 40.
On one side.
Oh, it's red.
No, wait.
This display panel right there.
Yes, I'm not gonna touch it.
I'm not gonna touch it.
How do I get close to it though?
Wait, it went to 47 now.
Wait, it was 40... Oh no, did I miss my chance?
It keeps going up now.
Is that it right there?
It was at 40 though.
Wandering Taco!
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you so much!
Do I have to go back to...
Will it ever go back?
It's only going up.
Oh no!
Hmm...
I probably have to see it though from my ship, right?
Well, I guess not.
Time to meditate.
Okay, we'll come back.
Okay, I got it though.
I got it.
I got what I gotta do.
Okay.
Okay, I understand why the meditating is useful to have here.
Should've bonked it on your way out.
You're so right.
Okay.
But, I might have to take a picture of it, probably.
It seems to be quantum.
So...
Okay, buckle up.
Here.
This is autopilot.
Here we go.
Okay.
Alrighty!
We got this, baby!
Just has to be at a forty-ish angle.
Ish.
I thought it might say something on the display panel, which is why I was like, oh, I should, you know.
I should read it.
But all it said was the degree.
So maybe now if I look at the sign...
Where is the display?
Oh, here.
Seventeen?
Eighteen?
Nineteen?
Okay, nineteen?
Twenty?
Plenty of time.
Twenty-two?
Twenty-three?
Wow, it just feels like we're not moving at all.
We're just in...
Twenty-five.
I'm gonna eat my...
dinner.
A little bit.
Not yet.
Wait.
Let's just go!
I don't want to match the velocity of the sun, though.
Oh, hold it down.
There we go.
I keep watching it.
I wish I would...
I could focus on this thing, though.
Go, go, go.
Here we go!
What's here?
Oh, this?
Can I get in here?
I think this is a...
A way in?
Kind of?
Nice landing!
Oh, just kidding.
Unbuckle.
Everything is good.
I think.
Wow.
We're inside!
What is this place?
Wow!
New aliens!
So cool!
I want to go up here, but maybe it's nothing.
Let's go inside.
Okay.
Have a great streaming, though!
Thank you!
What is this?
Unbuckle?
What if these guys aren't friendly?
Finally.
I just invaded their ship.
Unknown language.
Okay, interesting.
It turns my flashlight off.
What's this?
Rotate.
I'm on a ship.
Oh, and this is how I drive it.
Oh my gosh.
Uh oh.
What's happening?
This is how I drive it.
Oh my gosh.
It's Halo.
We're okay.
Nice.
That's exactly what I did.
I knew what was going to happen.
Is this an existing, alive species at the moment?
Official welcome to the DLC.
Enjoy the journey.
Thank you, Jeffrey!
Oh my god!
It looks like a church almost.
Ship log updated.
Yeah, I would think so.
Oh, it doesn't look so alive, after all.
Wow, they're huge.
We're teeny tiny.
They were playing Jenga.
Someone who has watched before.
Watched it before you even had 500 subs, let alone 100 viewers.
I'm so happy that you had a successful comeback.
Thank you so much.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Thanks for sticking around for so long.
Creepy.
Okay.
It's like, um, oh my gosh.
The things in, um...
It's like the, the guy, the deer guy in, uh...
Oh my gosh, why can't I think of that, the, um...
That show that I watch every Halloween.
Uh-oh, the sun is looking a little spicy, though.
Drop lantern.
Can't turn.
Oh, uh...
Cool.
Over the garden wall!
Yes, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Use interface.
Oh, wait.
Okay, nothing we can do here yet.
Oh, unless I have my flashlight on while I use it?
Oh no.
Turned it off.
The council.
Whoa!
They're so cool.
Yeah, it's like, uh...
It's like the over the garden wall guy.
They really are huge.
I'm a teeny tiny little alien.
These are giant aliens.
If I could go the reverse way.
Nah.
Can we watch it together this fall?
Maybe, yeah.
Why not?
I watch it every year.
Wow!
This place is so cool!
What's this?
Already holding lantern.
Remove...
Oh!
Sounds like this is the thing we need.
Oh.
I have to find a way to...
Oh, drop!
Drop.
I saw it.
I...
Drop...
Oh.
Not quite.
Look at this...
Chalice.
I'll just keep it there for now.
I don't know why I'm keeping this lantern.
It's broken.
Oh, there's another one.
Any more?
The ambience here.
Already holding slug.
Okay.
Hmm.
Something.
Do you know what a real is?
Yes!
Oh!
I forgot about...
I know what a real is.
Thank you very much.
Oh, probably needs though the lantern, right?
Maybe up top.
Are you sure?
Yes!
Ah!
I told you.
You were on just then!
I saw it!
It literally showed up on the screen!
Oh, but if I use my light, it works in the same way.
Interesting.
Um...
Oh!
No!
I think I just...
Oh!
What does this mean?
Mint, do you know what a lantern is?
Stop!
Okay, we'll go find another lantern.
Glad to see you returning to Outer Wilds.
Oh!
That one works over there.
I did truly only plan on taking this... doing this in like two streams, but...
It might take longer.
At this rate.
At my Minto pace.
Let's go up into here.
Maybe we can grab that.
Working lantern.
This is my first time...
Uh...
Oh, my first time I tried using the scout to light it.
Ah!
Oh see, here we go.
Space.
Little deer men.
Um...
In the bayou.
Chillaxin'.
Oh!
Ah!
I think we're fine.
Oh.
Um...
That's kind of scary.
All the lights go out.
Oh gosh, it's Titanic.
Oh, never let go, Jack.
Go to the boat!
Get on the boat!
Oh, I'm fine.
Don't mean a damn thing to me.
Get it?
We can continue onwards, actually.
Oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi...
We have
to get on to one of these like as it floods because we wouldn't reach it otherwise.
Like...
No!
Ah!
Hahaha!
Wait, this is the same place as before, isn't it not?
But they seem to, like, always... why are... ooh, see?
It looks just like the guy from Over the Garden Wall!
But it seems... these guys... seem to always exist in the dark.
Did I leave my bolt?
There it goes.
There's that place over there too.
We can still explore a little bit, even though we lost the dam.
Ahem.
Yeah, they like the dark.
I'm afraid of the dark.
Oh, wait, it's another... oh, it's this room.
But different.
I'm a little afraid of the dark, though.
Am I gonna not like this DLC?
I think I'm not gonna like this DLC.
If I'm afraid of the dark.
Oh god, it's so scary!
Stop turning on my flashlight!
Oh...
Oh no!
No!
We lost...
I'm such an idiot.
I knew that would happen, though.
Because I already saw it happen before.
The mirrors are starting to get darker.
What did you expect?
I forgot!
Oh yeah, we...
Remove slide window.
There were more.
Yeah, there were more.
Probably for people like me.
Wouldn't want to see any ghosts in the... Stop!
I'm afraid of other ghosts!
Any others in here?
Okay.
What's that sound?
Oh.
Okay, I think this just goes outside.
Yeah.
But I can swim!
I'm not so useless.
I can still swim!
Okay.
Where...
I think our boat is gone-gone.
Oh, there's another raft!
See?
I mean, I'm afraid of other humans.
It's not so weird, then, if I'm afraid of other ghosts.
Our boat is gone-gone.
Huh.
Let's...
So...
Does the sun not explode here?
Or is that what caused the...
The...
You know...
Oh, gosh.
It's getting really dark in here!
Oh, gosh!
It's scary!
Is that what caused the dam to break?
I did see the sun through here.
But...
Oh!
No!
You son of a bitch!
You son of
a bitch!
I'm afraid of what happens when I take all of these.
Because it's getting really dark in here.
It's getting really dark in there.
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
We got the stuff in there.
Damnit!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you so, so much!
Thank you!
Oh, my goodness.
Why are you guys gifting so much?
I've gotten, like...
There was even an Akasupa I saw before...
Before the stream even started!
The eye!
The eye and...
Matara-Khan...
Lantern...
Space.
I'm scared.
What's...
I'm scared!
They are also looking at the eye.
Wait.
Are they trying to find the eye, too?
It's a motion picture.
They're scanning the eye.
It's a bird.
Oh, my God.
He's observing the power of the eye.
Oh!
He's making the eye...
He's corrupting the eye!
The eye will say so until he happens.
The eye is destroying the universe.
Hello?
What?
Oh!
And him, too.
Nature.
Happens.
Oh!
I feel loved and supported, nerds.
We are...
If the eye is against us, we are against the eye.
Wait.
So, they worship the eye.
See, him and then...
They were like, no, the eye doesn't...
Destroy all...
All worship of the eye.
The eye is evil.
The eye is...
The music is so scary.
What are they doing there?
Something is going to pop up.
Mitochondria is the powerhouse of the cell.
Oh.
And this is our...
This is our solar system.
Because there's Timber Hearth.
There's...
There's Brutal Hall.
Yeah.
There's the Ash Twins.
Oh, here we come.
Oh.
Eclipse.
This has been here the whole time?
Let's do the next one.
I wish the music would come back.
It's...
Otherwise, it's so...
It's so quiet.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I think that's our signal.
We're running out of time.
A bit.
Oh, our boat.
Well, good thing we got the lantern before it.
Yeah, there's another side.
Don't worry.
I'm going to go look at it.
Just wanted to make sure.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no, no, no.
Wait.
Uh...
I don't like that.
Why did you take that picture, you weirdo?
What is that thing?
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, it locks...
It locks...
Wait.
But there was three eyes in the picture of Matara.
So, it locks it if...
If we...
So, if we stop...
If we lock up the eye, it will stop from destroying us?
Just for fun?
We have to get this guy to absorb into what is going on in the...
Ship log updated.
Okay.
At least we got that before we got eaten by the sun.
Oh, ouch.
So, this is probably of some significance.
Before...
And...
Oh, see?
See?
It's like...
Oh, shoot.
Oh, bleh, bleh, bleh, bleh.
Hold on.
I'm not done, son.
I'm not done yet.
Shoot.
Okay.
There we go.
Hello?
Son?
Are you going to...
Are you going to blow us up or...
Or what?
Oh!
There we go.
Interesting.
Oh man, I'm going to have to go find this place again, aren't I?
Kind of sucks.
Sorry, I'm eating cucumber.
Oh!
Hey, hold up a sec.
Yeah, yeah, I'm here.
Yeah, I already know about the launch codes.
How convenient!
Incredible ideas!
Oh, I do the best I can with what I've got.
Really, you're too kind.
Slate, you are a technological marvel.
Whoa!
Say that again, please!
That sounds so good when it's not sarcastic.
Anyways, I've got a fire to enjoy.
And you've got launch codes to grab.
Go wild with the marking feature while you're out there.
Just try not to follow it so directly you fly into the sun, okay?
I would never do that!
I would never, ever, ever do that.
Is there a stranger?
A massive artificial ring world hidden within some sort of cloaking field.
It does not appear to be Hearthian or Nomian in origin.
A slide wheel from the Cinder Isles.
Showed a glowing symbol and chains appear around a strange vault.
Bless you.
Thank you.
A pair of small rocky islands connected by a village of stilt houses.
There's more to explore here.
A slide wheel that shows the stranger's inhabitants analyzing the eye of the universe.
Several slides have been burned and cannot be viewed.
I wonder if we can find one that hasn't been burned.
A low-lying region near the entrance to the stranger.
There are wooden buildings along the banks of the river.
Oh my goodness, we have so much to explore now.
Mark location!
Yippee!
There's the stranger!
Good morning!
Oh!
Bye, Adlerock.
So if I just go like this...
Will I reach it?
There we go.
Stranger danger.
Inward!
Oh gosh.
Oh, I have to...
I have to do all of this again, though.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Ah!
Wait!
We're fine.
Um...
Yup.
Perfect.
Perfect!
See you, guys.
Oh my god.
My own footsteps scared me.
I thought I heard, like, someone else walking around.
Flawless.
I know.
Oh, one second.
Um...
Ghosts are super effective against other ghosts, so it makes sense for you to be afraid.
Exactly.
I see the best landing.
Thank you!
Keep going.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
How did I do it so flawlessly before?
Wait.
No, no, no, no.
No.
I don't want to say it.
Stop it.
Just scare yourself all the time.
All the time.
Chubby!
Welcome back for your trip.
Thank you!
Stop!
I did it, like, so perfectly before.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's go.
Come on.
I'm piloting you.
Let's go.
Believe in yourself.
Oh, I have to push it.
Where should we go?
Oh, there's so much to explore.
Wait, this is a ghost mato.
Oh, this has ghost matter written all over it.
Did the ghost matter also kill them too?
What the hell is that?
What was that?
Did you guys see that?
It just...
It disappeared out of existence.
There was like a little egg and it was dancing.
Oh, it's that thing up there.
That symbol.
Can we get in at all?
Oh,
it's hard when it's sideways.
No, there was something there.
I promise.
Be careful.
That's me.
Be careful, guys.
Be careful.
Oh, no.
Can I even get inside?
I'm dead.
I fell off.
Oh my God.
That was so stupid.
Oh man.
Oh, fell off... ratio.
Yeah, keep the HUD marker there.
I can't do this.
That's all we're going, baby.
Nowhere else to go.
My throat doesn't hurt, I just can't stop coughing.
Check for the egg again.
Yeah, we should!
We should!
That was a dancing egg!
I knew it!
I saw it!
Okay.
Easy.
Easy does it.
Ah, perfect landing.
Where's the door?
There it is.
Hey!
Perfect landing.
Flawless.
Nice flip.
Thank you.
Blub, blub, blub, blub.
There we go.
Yippee!
Alright, let's get that egg.
Oh, uh, push the raft.
It's over there!
There's an egg!
I promise you!
Yeah!
Crash into it!
What?
Uh... I prom... I promise there was an egg.
Oh my god.
I promise you, there was something there.
It was... it was... it was dancing around!
It was!
It was there!
No way!
It can't be gone!
Well, let's land here.
Maybe.
Here.
Yup.
Right here.
Exactly where I wanted to land.
What the...
Oh, it's a goodbye ship.
There was something there!
Oh, oh, I pressed the wrong button.
Gotcha!
This is where... we were before, is it not?
Okay.
Yeah, I remember all these portraits and stuff.
Yeah.
God, these guys are kind of vain, aren't they?
Sure.
I promise.
It was there.
No, this is actually a different one.
But we need a lantern.
A working lantern.
No, you're just meant...
Please, the VOD.
The VOD will save my sanity.
This is a bad dad family portrait.
Look how many they have, though!
Actually, I want to keep just kind of exploring, like, other places a little bit.
I can't... I can't do anything there anyway, because I don't have a working lantern.
Look at them!
There's pictures of these guys everywhere!
I want to see, like, what this is, too.
Oh, this is for the boat!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Jeffrey, what did you put in Mint's oxygen tanks?
I swear there was something there!
I promise!
I wouldn't just make that up!
Broken lantern...
Why would I make that up?
Why would I say there's an egg there, and not mean it?
Wait, um...
Okay, okay, okay.
Ahem.
This is where I was at before.
Okay, so we have been to all of this then.
We have seen these then.
Maybe it just looked different because it was all sunken underwater.
She's not lying, she's just haunted.
She would absolutely make it up!
Yeah, I would.
You're right.
You're a soup!
Thank you!
Says the girl who made up the face in the mirror.
Oh, no, see, this is Nil!
Okay, I'm not crazy.
As crazy as I thought.
The eye goes...
Whoa!
Okay, that's their planet.
And they were like...
What is this?
What is... Wow!
It's powering our stuff!
Whoa-ee!
Whoa, I'm seeing everything.
Oh my God!
He's grabbing his antlers.
He's so shocked.
What?
Oh my God!
Hey, come look at this!
Whoa!
Woo!
They're really trying hard to delete this evidence.
And so they built their little...
They built their space thing.
Their portable planet.
And they went...
Pew!
All the way!
They hid their trade secrets.
It's kind of messed up.
And then they were like...
Okay, let's go meet the eye of the universe!
Okay.
Yeah, there's three eyes on the MataraCon machine.
I'm scared of the spooky, because some people were like...
I had to stop playing this because it got too spooky.
And I'm scared when...
It's a little eerie right now, but I'm afraid of the real spooky happening.
That's another...
So glad you're playing, Peek.
Hope you're having a good time.
Your volume is low.
What do you mean by that?
I'm scared now!
The vault is open.
The vault is closing.
Oh no!
Not this guy again!
Stay away from me!
Oh.
He's going to this machine again.
And lighting it up.
And...
Oh!
It seals it.
Okay.
Oh God.
Why did I stop it on that one?
Okay, let's get out of here.
Let's just leave.
Okay.
Alright, let's keep going down the bayou.
Going down the bayou.
Are we stuck stuck?
Push the raft.
Okay.
Oh, nope.
No!
I guess that works.
Ooh, why is it flickering?
It's interesting.
That's an interesting effect.
And then we got our nice music.
Calm and good.
Okay.
And... okay, so that's where we went to before, for sure.
Oop!
That is where we went to before, for sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we haven't gone any further beyond this.
But I'm curious, what is some of these parts over here that were under the water?
You know?
Let's check it out.
No projection cells.
It's just the alien version of yelling audio to you.
Ouch!
Beam me up!
Thank you!
This DLC is almost like a theme park dark ride.
I sure hope not.
I sure hope it's not like a dark ride.
It's my 30th birthday a few days ago!
I'm now a decade closer to becoming a ghost.
This is the church they burned!
Becky, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Becky.
I would clap, but we're on a time limit.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Sorry I'm late.
Okay.
This is a boat.
Let's go over to this area.
I haven't used my signal scope.
I wonder if there's anything.
Nope.
Makes sense though.
But what happened to these guys?
Did they get eaten by the eye?
A family tree?
This is so much more mysterious.
I want to go to the top of this building.
But...
I don't know how.
There were stairs that lead inside.
But there's not stairs that lead up.
Maybe they autopiloted into the sun.
They could have.
Very possible.
Very probable.
More likely than you think.
Okay.
So these are all just like little houses and stuff.
This one was under the water too though.
They found the eye directly.
Oh, my skill issue.
It's so funny because the...
Oh.
Interesting.
Okay.
This...
The eye...
Is missing part of his antlers.
But it's funny because the Nomai were just like...
Yo.
Our guy is like...
What is this?
Our guy...
Like the...
We...
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh.
What is this?
Hold on.
Sorry.
I'm trying to talk and then I'm like discovering stuff all at the same time.
Interesting.
My cat says...
Good morning, Minto.
Good morning, Kato.
What building is that?
And it leads into a cave.
Okay.
Yeah.
Like a hidden room.
But yeah.
The Nomai were just like...
It's calling to us.
But like...
I think the eye was actually calling to these guys.
Oh.
This one right here maybe.
That might be how I get inside to the...
To the...
What's the word?
Not the elevator.
That's not the correct word.
The staircase.
Right?
Oh.
There it is.
Okay.
This way.
Over.
Inside.
This way.
Oh.
It's really scary in here.
I don't like this.
Oh.
It's really dark.
Goodness.
Okay.
To the cave we go.
We learn about it.
We go...
Search it out.
Oh.
I was right.
It is the staircase.
Okay.
I like that.
But sometimes I, I like it a little bit.
We found another treasure.
Do this.
Oh.
Yeah.
Ah.
Not here.
There's no exit here?
I think I found something.
Okay.
Yep.
Alright.
Thank you!
Welcome back for two mines!
Thank you so much.
So I'll read a book...
Let's see, what is this?
What is this doing?
Powering...
To the house, to the tower...
To the hidden hobbit home...
To the grand bell...
It's a good thing I'm up here!
My boat...
I need to get down there though, right?
We have to get down there and then we have to do the lantern thing all over again.
Yeah, I need to find a working projector.
There's one in there!
Oh!
Oh my gosh, we're watching it fall apart in real time.
Oh, it's fine.
It all okay, baby.
Okay.
Barely a scratch, tis but a flesh wound.
Right?
Okay, insert that.
And let's go find a working lantern, which we know where to get one.
More lugs!
Toki!
Do a flip.
Toki, you make jokes but you'd be too baby to play this game, I know it.
Your bird brain wouldn't even be able to figure stuff out.
We're gonna be playing this...
I looked up the game we're playing on Friday and it looks so...
It looks very...
I can't wait for Kusoge.
Alright, let's look at whatever the hell this thing is.
Ooh!
Oh!
Oh, it's that symbol.
Okay.
Toki bird coded?
Maybe.
Wait, let me mod you real quick.
Sorry, every time I click out of the game, that's what chat is for.
I almost clicked hide.
Hide user on this channel.
There we go.
Okay.
He's looking.
He's walking.
Who's taking these photos?
They're so atmospheric.
These guys are so dramatic.
Ooh!
He's looking at the camera.
Ah!
Is that you?
Oh!
It's me!
Me asking.
You?
Cool.
What?
If you remove the light...
Wait, which one was it?
Okay, it's the one where he's staring at Saturn.
Secret title!
This is not a cult, right?
Meep, welcome back.
Thank you.
Meep has been called for work.
Me shall see the body.
Good luck with work!
It's all of them.
It's anything with this symbol.
Has a secret passage.
I like the footage of all the...
Okay.
Very cool.
I liked that one.
That was a cool, that was a cool...
Discovery.
Wait, so we can go... do it here then, right?
I'd join.
There is no Saturn!
Interesting.
So it's not this one.
Maybe it's the one from up the river.
There was?
No, there wasn't!
Unless you mean... this one.
But it's not the same picture.
I'm just gonna...
Don't mind me.
Oh shoot.
Come on.
Toast it to perfection!
Yes!
Anyway...
These guys are so huge.
This guy is knocked the hell out!
I want what he had.
He's just like...
This guy too!
He took one too many melatonin.
Don't touch the fire.
I guess.
My bad.
Well, this is a little freaky.
I guess this answers the question where they went.
But there's one missing and I don't like that very much!
I don't like that very much.
I cannot believe that I can roast marshmallows in the...
In the ghost matter fire.
Okay.
This one's...
No.
Oh, I thought it was not lit.
But it's...
It's litty.
Wait.
Did this guy move?
Or was...
He always kind of slouched over.
I sure hope not.
Okay.
Room for one more.
I'm into...
Okay.
This is not a cold...
Oh god!
Where's the entrance?
Oh!
Yes!
There we go!
It sure doesn't seem like a cold.
Not at all.
Okay.
Let's go to this boat over here.
Maybe we can even continue a little bit onward.
We'll have to swim for a bit.
Okay.
Nice.
And up.
Not a cold.
Okay.
This way.
This is the furthest we've been now.
Not a cold.
It sounds like I'm saying nautical.
Oh!
That doesn't seem...
Okay.
Oh!
Don't fall in the water here.
Okay.
Good to know.
Don't fall in the water there or else you're nautical.
Nautical.
This area looks a little gnarly.
What's over here?
Ship log update.
With what?
Over...
Oh!
Here.
This way.
I like the music.
It plays like such whimsical music every time I'm going around.
Oh!
Is there nothing here?
Wait a second.
There's a secret cave!
Right...
Right there.
Oh.
Well.
It's our time anyway.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll bet you guys...
And there goes our boat.
It's our time anyway.
Next to the egg.
I swear I saw something there.
I know I saw something there.
It was like morbing and then it...
It went...
Out of existence!
I saw it.
Oh, I wanna go up there.
I wanna go up here.
I wanna go up.
Where am I?
Can we?
Ow!
So close.
Not quite.
It's really trippy to look at.
It seems like it's much bigger too than it actually is, I guess.
Because it's just a loop, right?
Is there a floor?
We'll just ride down the lazy river until we die.
Wow!
Oh!
Ouch!
I'm surprised I lived.
I lived just to die.
Can we go this way?
I still want to explore.
Come on, game!
I'm trapped.
Wait!
Didn't I go to this house in the very beginning?
Oh!
You have boost.
It's OK.
I was dying anyway.
I was living on borrowed time.
We did a lot that time though.
We did a whole lot.
Look at that!
That was a really full...
That was a super full trip.
Who knows now?
OK.
Let's see.
We'll do a few more loops though.
Because I'm still very curious as to...
what else we got going on in here.
Ooh!
Wow!
OK.
An enormous reservoir with wooden piers and buildings on both shores.
There's more to explore here.
Oh!
Who is naming this place, huh?
Are we just coming up with our own names?
We can't even read the language!
Slide reel that shows the origins of the stranger and its inhabitants.
Several slides have been burned and cannot be viewed.
Source me.
A tower that sits atop one of the cinder aisles.
The upper floors can only be reached from a second entrance at the back of the tower.
I found a slide reel.
I don't know why I cannot say slide reel.
That shows the stranger's inhabitants opening a secret passage in a round room filled with lanterns and murals.
The inhabitants are shown filing into three of these rooms throughout the room.
What does this mean about the stranger?
We'll call them cinder aisles and island tower and actual names, but the ship itself is just the stranger.
You can talk to the guy at the museum about the language, but it doesn't change anything in the game.
Oh!
I kind of want to ask, though.
I want to know what he says.
A pair of small rocky islands connected by a village of stilt houses.
I found a large metal symbol for the eye of the universe inside a burned-out building.
Yes, we did.
Yes, indeed, we did.
Oh, wait.
Well, it's fine.
Come on, stranger.
I'm coming for you.
I'm on my way.
Autopilot.
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
I'm coming for you.
Stranger?
Howdy, stranger.
Don't be a stranger now.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, down.
It's forward.
Forward march.
Down.
And...
A perfect landing.
You good?
Oh!
Am I sideways?
How would I do that?
Dang it.
Awesome.
Like a glove.
So why does this thing...
I have to wonder.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot that we have to push it.
Why does this thing blow up anyway?
This dam.
Why does it blow up anyway?
Also, I noticed some stairs over here, which I am quite curious about.
Look.
The music didn't even have a chance.
There we go.
Take a look.
Oh, I will.
I will be taking a look.
Damn if you do, damn if you don't.
This is the house I was just trying to get to before!
No way.
Oh goodness.
Okay, that's a boat.
Why is it so dark in here?
Why is it so scary?
What's this?
Rotate.
Why is everything got to be so dramatic?
What the?
Oh!
It's just another...
It's just another entrance.
Are you kidding me?
Another ship bay.
Yeah.
And it would have led me down this way instead.
Ah!
Interesting, interesting, interesting.
Okay.
Well, fire exit.
Now we know.
That's how you first come in.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh, whoop.
And push the raft, push the raft, push the raft.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Don't leave!
I'm searching for an egg.
I swear.
It was here.
I swear it!
We still have to find a way to get inside there.
Oops.
I pushed a little.
Okay.
What was another place that had...
Not in there.
Here.
This place also had...
The... what's it called?
The lantern and stuff.
Jeffrey, is the egg real?
Don't do this to me.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
This is the initial one that we saw.
Drop it.
Wow.
So cool.
Okay.
Here we go.
I hope there's no more dead bodies down here.
Or else I'm really going to think this is a coal.
Oh, no!
I'm really, really, really starting to believe that this is a coal.
I'm really having some suspicions.
This one sounds different.
But also, all the guys are here.
So only at that other one was it missing somebody.
Totally not a coal.
Okay.
Let's get out of here.
How do you think they taste?
They look like they would taste like chicken feet.
Which I've never tried before.
So you'll have to ask Matara.
I'm like...
I'm like struggling to remember where I've gone.
Oh, wait.
I wish I could push the raft outside the raft.
So we're just going to continue onward.
Chicken feet are good when marinated well.
She, like, lives by it.
She's just like, chicken feet are so delicious.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
We went all through there.
So let's just keep going.
I haven't had chicken feet I like.
I think...
Why does it get like that here?
I did it before also.
I love the music on the raft.
It's so cool.
So these are the electric wires.
Have I gone...
Let's go over here.
I haven't really gone over this way before.
So...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Please.
Is it too strong?
The current?
Uh...
No.
Oh, well.
It's okay.
We're exploring.
Yeah.
Today's your birthday.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Dear.
Yeah.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
I hope you guys don't mind me not clapping like I usually do.
But like I said, I'm on a bit of a time limit with this game.
So I've got to move as fast as I can.
Oh, another puzzle.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Okay.
We'll come back.
We'll come back to that.
I don't think...
I might have the stuff for that, but I'm not quite sure.
The knowledge.
Not quite sure if I have the knowledge yet.
But there was another building over here, so...
Okay.
Clap now.
Andrey goes, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Yep.
Thank you.
Ooh.
Lantern.
Oh.
I don't want any of them to smile.
Maybe they can't.
They're like, we're bird people.
We don't know how to smile.
We're bird deer people.
Oh, oh, oh, goodness.
Does this just lead outside?
Let's go.
Okay.
Let's just go.
No, no, please!
It's too dark!
Oh, it's
too close.
Oh, are you kidding me?
Oh my god.
I'm getting spooked for no reason!
This is a nice view.
The door to darkness.
Quite literally.
I wonder if we can see the water rising.
So we need...
We need another...
Another, uh...
Slide.
Reel.
And let's try going into this other building over here.
Wait!
Literally trolled.
There's this building here, but there's this one right here.
And if we just jump right in, maybe we can...
See what goes on here.
Can we fix the dam?
Don't launch sideways.
Silly.
Oh, that's me.
Ah!
Oh!
I'm scared though.
What if I launch the scout and I see a guy standing there?
I'm gonna be scared.
Okay.
Sun.
I.
Fire.
I fire.
Sun.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Oh.
Oh, I can just look at it.
No, I can't.
Sun.
Or is it...
Yeah, okay.
Sun.
I.
Fire.
Wait, which I is it?
There's two of them.
No, there's not.
Fire.
Yippee!
Oh.
Come back, scout.
Thought I heard something.
This game's making me a little bit paranoid.
This game's making me just a tad paranoid.
Just a tad.
This thing's been destroyed.
Ooh.
Uh oh.
Don't worry, you're alone.
That doesn't make me feel very good.
Wee-woo.
No... something.
No grabby hand.
Oh look, it's new guys.
Oh, these guys look like real travelers.
Like real spacemen.
It's a password.
Which maybe you shouldn't just have like...
...Lion straight open.
I got in so easily.
No chicken feet for you.
Yeah, it's the chicken foot.
Okay.
Hmm.
I like how it's decorated with their antlers.
They have a nice design choice.
You don't hang up your password as art?
Whatever next background I commission, I'm just gonna have my passwords in the background.
You'll never know.
This was...
I'm okay.
Alright.
I tried to go to that before and we couldn't.
I don't think I can make it now.
For sure.
There's a light up there.
I'm so sorry.
Sorry.
I'm drinking water.
Okay.
I wonder if I can get up there.
Oh god.
I lived.
My vitals are low.
Maybe I should just meditate at this point.
Or that.
I can't stop coughing.
Why?
Yeah,
I'll get a cough drop.
I think I have some in here.
Sorry.
I might have to call it here.
I can breathe though.
I can breathe.
Let me try warm hot water for that cough.
I have.
Yeah.
Let's see how... if the cough drop helps at all.
Let's see if the cough drop helps at all.
I want to make it to that other building that was on the other side.
But I can't make it to once it breaks.
I'm so sorry.
No, Kai.
If I stop though, if I have to stop.
If I feel like I have to stop though, I will.
I have some hot water and natural honey.
Yeah, I have been.
If this is how it felt like though when I was...
When I was... when I first got sick.
When I was like...
Oh!
I didn't even go inside.
It did it for me.
Nice.
Oh!
Coming in hot!
Wonk.
We're okay.
Just move over a little bit.
We're fine.
Oh!
Why is it so fast in here?
Where's the floor?
Oh!
Whatever.
I couldn't tell where the floor was.
Oh!
Yay!
It fixed itself.
Okay.
So we're going to ride all the way down this dam.
Oh!
Wait a second.
There we go.
Ignore the ghost egg.
Landed sideways again.
I meant to do that.
Obviously.
Duh!
There's a dock I missed.
There is?
What dock did I miss?
Hello.
Keep going.
Whoa!
You missed the egg too.
No.
You guys missed the egg.
That's the first thing I'm going to...
Whoa!
That's the first thing I'm going to check as soon as I'm done with this.
I'm going to watch the VOD for this.
Oh!
Thanks for the $50 gift.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
This cough drop is already helping so much.
Wait.
I need to go on this side.
So that's the destroyed temple.
Whoa!
This feels like I'm on a... like a theme park ride.
Okay.
It's through here.
Oh!
There's this dock.
That's right.
Oh!
This is this one.
I can't reach it though.
I missed it again.
But it's okay.
It's not our destination.
I love this game.
It's fine.
It's not our destination.
Two lights can back up.
Oh, really?
See that?
That's what I want to go see.
Whoa!
Nice.
That's what I want to see.
Because it lifts up once the dam breaks.
So once the dam breaks, we cannot... we cannot go through to it anymore.
This sign won't stop me because I can't read.
It's broken.
Whoa.
Cough drop helped so much.
Goody good good.
What's that?
It was a chair.
And this one's also broken.
They probably said welcome in anyway.
Probably.
Huh.
How do we...
Is it time?
Let's go.
Do I just have to wait?
I wonder.
Can a scout get inside?
Hmm.
Let's try.
I don't want to wait until the dam breaks because that will take forever.
No, I don't think so.
I think every single person I've seen play this, and myself included, made that joke.
It's like so easy.
You know?
Because you literally can't read it.
What a great view though.
Just bash it in.
We're preserving the integrity of the location.
Well, this was kind of a bust then.
If we have to wait all the way until...
Let me try.
Getting to the...
Onto the roof.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
It's me.
Uh-oh.
Huh?
Something...
Lifts in here and then it causes the dam to break.
Sorry, I tripped the...
I switched the cable.
The flicker is so spooky.
I know, right?
Because it like affects the whole map.
Sorry for me clearing my throat every two seconds.
Huh.
So this is all gonna break.
I saw some stairs here.
Oh, where does it go into?
Ouch.
We're fine.
Okay.
What's this?
I don't...
Oh, okay.
It's just a bunch of chairs.
Oh, the council.
Look it.
They saved the best seats for themselves.
The sun.
You have cooties.
I think so right now.
Yeah.
Unfortunately.
Please still love me even if I had cooties.
Oh, where are we going?
Okay.
I mean, it wasn't a total bust, I guess.
I'm scared.
Yeah.
Even better.
Don't be a freak.
Oh, I forgot to read the shiplog.
After the last one.
The sun?
This is their thing right now.
And I'm guessing... I feel like it would be a different symbol for the eye, right?
This is the stranger.
Danger.
Yeah, it's moving away.
Yeah, I noticed that too.
It's like pointed towards somewhere.
Minto still going, eh?
Just for a little bit longer.
I do want to get through enough progress that I feel comfortable that I could potentially finish tomorrow.
What's this?
Oh, okay.
Rotate.
Water?
Oh, it like resets it.
Right?
Huh.
It's a long DLC.
Oh!
Ow!
Oh, it's up and down!
We've got a lot to go.
That's okay.
Oh!
Oh, wait.
Keep going down.
Maybe?
Oh, we're here?
Already?
Okay.
Don't go!
Don't leave me!
Oh!
What?
It's my ship!
We've discovered a hidden way to get back.
Oh, it's a shortcut!
Let's go.
I think when I saw what it said for the DLC, it said like 12 hours or something.
But...
If I have to go in three tries, that's okay too.
Though I did want to keep it all together so that the information is fresh in my brain.
But that's okay.
So far, I'm loving this.
I'm scared.
We're right on top of it.
And it's going to blow at any second.
It's going to collapse at any second, you guys.
This is so dangerous!
Oh, God!
If I was feeling better, I would endurance more of this for sure.
That's where we started.
Oh, you can see it leaking through.
Oh, my God!
It's going to blow!
It's going to blow at any second now!
We have a full week this time.
Pace yourself.
Yeah!
I'm just going to slowly walk across the bridge back to the house.
You know, just taking my time.
How do I get back up there, though?
Cool, we discovered that shortcut.
That's fine.
I just got to get back to the house, I think, before...
before the dam breaks.
Or...
this thing.
It, like, lifts up.
But so does the... the house also lifts up.
Stand on it and wait.
You're immortal.
Run to the house!
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Here's the house!
Does this thing lift up or am I cra...
There goes my boat.
Eventually.
That's the... that's... I remember seeing this in one of the...
In one of the... slides, though.
Maybe I only thought that this lifted up because the water drained so much.
I think... I think that's the... what happened.
The water drained so much that I thought the house lifted up.
But it actually just stays in place and we just couldn't reach it before.
You bitch!
It's all about perspective.
I don't think I can do anything on here.
Though I am curious about...
about a spot... about the ghost matter spot now.
Is that all over... is that flooded?
Oh!
All places.
I had to...
Oh my god.
Well, let's go check it out if we can.
Hopefully I won't die trying to get there.
Because this water gets a little rough right here.
Let's go check out the ghost matter.
We're okay.
We made it!
This is the ghost matter over here.
Was the ghost matter with you?
Maybe it hates water.
Okay.
Oh!
That's promising though, right?
Yeah!
That's actually promising.
Okay, let's go in.
We can go in now.
Oh no!
There's a thingy!
Wait.
Can I pick this up?
Maybe that's not what I think.
Oh.
These people are just rich.
Maybe.
Let's try there.
Ship log updated.
Nice.
Okay.
Cool.
Good stuff.
What the heck?
Oh!
These are the things that they're holding!
I thought it was a...
I thought it was a slide.
No!
These are the things that they're holding!
Okay.
So, there was a symbolic...
What was the symbol in this place?
That!
The things that they're holding!
Okay.
What would you... what would you... look at that!
The little lanterns, yeah!
Who would have thunk?
Looks like you can get in from underneath.
But our ship log updated, so I wonder if we even need to come back.
Unless there's more stuff in here that we can't see because...
But I think there's also gonna be more... I think there's more ghost matter in there.
So I think maybe... we wouldn't be able to come in anyway.
But I will come back.
Just in case.
I wish I could get a boat.
Ouch.
Any boats available?
Okay, so besides that one other dock...
Is there any other place that... I mean, I know there's so much still left...
But what haven't we done?
Oh, there was another... there was another in the slides...
There was another one of these places, but it was a hole...
In the... in the ground.
It was like a little...
It was like a little cavern type one.
Still no egg, by the way.
That's because it... disappears!
The egg remains elusive!
Because it was literally there and then it disappears!
Quantum egg!
But I was staring at it.
I watched it go... I watched it fade out of existence.
I wonder if I can make it to that one.
There's a log over there.
Oh, there's another ship.
Come here, boat!
Come here!
Ouch, so close!
Nice.
Hey, hey, hey!
No pirates!
Echoes of the egg.
It could have been the eye this whole time.
You don't know!
Keep your eyes peeled for another...
Another place.
Another...
I'll have to look at the slideshow again, maybe.
The egg of the universe.
Wait, so if I fall in the water here, am I done-zo?
Am I, like, for real done-zo?
I wanna see.
This is the spot that we couldn't get to before, right?
Or maybe we could.
I can't remember, actually.
Oh!
There's so much here!
Wait a second.
Well, time to die.
This will be...
The next thing we explore...
Tomorrow!
Shabir, welcome to the membership!
Thank you!
I hope I said your name right.
Jump for it!
Okay!
Yoooooo!
Even
though I really, really wanna explore it right now.
But, um...
I really wanna explore it right now.
But, since I'm playing this again tomorrow...
I will refrain.
Dramatic music cuts out.
I'm not even gonna give...
I'm not gonna let the sun have the satisfaction, okay?
Are you still gonna do the direct watch-along?
Oh yeah!
Tomorrow's a Nintendo direct.
Um, I plan on doing a watch-along.
Because, um, you guys...
There's a little game called Tomodachi Life.
That I'm doing a summoning circle for.
And if a ghost does a summoning circle...
It is like ten times more effective.
So...
Um, it's quite early.
Oh my gosh, I just realized what time it is.
Oh my goodness.
Uh...
The stream is kind of early.
So I'll do my best.
It's actually when my alarm typically goes off.
So...
Thanks for the stream!
I love the vibes of this DLC.
I hope you get some rest and feel better soon.
Thank you!
Um...
But, uh...
But, um...
Yeah, this is usually when I wake up.
So...
Uh...
We'll see.
We'll see if I...
I'll make a waiting room for it tonight, though.
Um...
And I might be a little...
I might be a little few minutes late or something.
Who knows?
DLC...
Is a great addition to an obviously special game.
Glad you're enjoying it.
It's so cool to see how differently you learn and progress through it.
Right?
It's so cool!
I appreciate it.
I hope you feel better soon, Minto.
Thank you!
I'm gonna rest my voice...
My throat lots tonight.
Um...
So...
Hopefully I can get over...
Over this sickness.
Man...
You can all blame Mataro.
Um...
But yeah!
Awesome, Minto!
Thank you, guys!
Um...
We'll play more of this tomorrow.
And if I see you at the direct, I'll see you at the direct.
Bye!
If you have secrets for throat recovery, it's not my throat though.
It's like in my chest, you know?
That's making me cough.
So...
Uh...
Though the...
The...
The cough drop did help.
Um...
Down with the sickness.
Down with the sickness!
Down with it!
Down boy, down!
But yeah!
Um...
Take care of yourself, man.
Thank you!
Thank you, guys!
Hope your cough goes away.
Thank you!
Are you watching the direct live?
Yes, I would watch it live.
If I...
If I make it.
I'll
see you guys tomorrow for more!
For more Outer Wilds.
And we'll explore more stuff and uncover more mystery!
And if I have to do it in...
two more streams.
So, in a three-parter.
That's okay too.
No worries.
Thank you!
I love listening to this though.
Hold on, let's go find a nice...
Let's go find a nice little spot to relax.
I don't wanna look at the sun.
Where's the planet?
I'm so short.
I've been meaning to...
Oh!
The interloper!
I've been meaning to get the soundtrack for this.
When I was buying it again, I tried to get the soundtrack.
But it was like...
It was weird on Steam, so...
Okay!
Okay, Otsumito for real.
Message is short.
I love how stranger is he.
Okay.
Bye, guys!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
See you tomorrow!
See you!
Bye-bye!